こんにちははじめｓｙ...あー、ハジ―ポッターです(?)
えー、みなさん「ハリーポッター」見たことありますでしょうか？
ハリーポッターの中で、僕的にはもっとも怖いであろう
「ディメンター」という吸魂鬼がいます。
ディメンターとは、非存在の闇の生物であり世界で最も悍ましい生き物とされている。「吸魂鬼」は人間の幸福をエサにし、近くにいる人に絶望と憂鬱をもたらす。彼らは、また、人間の魂を奪うことができ、奪われた人間は永遠の昏睡状態に陥る。
こわい
ディメンターていうやつらがいるんですけど、黒いふわふわした。
それが、こう、人に寄っていくと人は抜け殻になっちゃって
恐ろしい生き物がいます
今回これからまさきが家に来るんですけども、
今、私の家には大量のデゥメンターが発生しております。
ディメンターここのうしろにも何人かいるんですけども
これからまさきが家に遊びにきて僕ン家に住むディメンターが彼の魂を狙いにきます。
ディメンターをどうやって、こう、退けるかというと
エクスぺクスパトローナ(間違っています)という呪文を唱えなければいけません。
なんでなの！？
ディメンターを追い払うゆういつ「エクスペクトパトローナム」というのがあります。
この呪文をとなえると守護霊が呼ぶことができて、吸魂鬼を追い払うことがでる呪文 。
まさきが助かる方法は、
杖を持ちディメンターに向かってエクスペクトパトローナムを唱えるしかない。
これが彼の助かるゆういつの方法です。
ではドッキリスタート
はい！
はーい
夜あるし忙しいでしょ？
ちぇ
まぁ　WiiUじゃない、スイッチして落ち着こうや
な、なんでポッター殿(?)になってんの？
まさき　ハリーポッター見たことある？
あるあるある
なんでなんでなんでw
ワ―！！
ヤァー！！
まさき！早く逃げるんだ！ディメンターだ！
早く早く!
玄関！玄関！
あー！ディメンター！
下だ！下　下だ！
あー！ディメンター！上しかない！はやく！
魂吸いとられつるるついとまられるよ(?)！上しかない！
さ、げんｋ、ベランダしかない！ベランダしかない！うわーーー！
そちゅみゅうな！もう！(?)
あーーー！
やばい！
あれを唱えるしかない！
早くとなえるしかない！
なんだっけ、なんだっけ
あれを唱えるしか！
「エクスペクトパトローナム」
よく覚えてたね
エンディングテーマ(原曲:「レトロゲームセンター」　甘茶の音楽工房)